This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
让自己经历一些磨难，你就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有比这更重要的年份了，对黑人来说。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要使用它。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控让人生下双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，莱斯利。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在Iheart广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定采取行动。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody.
我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。大家好。
I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our 20s. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here, back for another episode. Can I tell you guys a story to start this episode off? The story that inspired me to do this episode. So the other day, I was at this bathhouse, like spa thing when I was back in Australia for a week. This spa is like our go-to place. Like when I lived there, I used to go there probably once a week. It has this like huge pool, this like soak thing, this like cold plunge sauna,
我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《心理学：你的20多岁》，这是一个我们讨论20多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能来到这里，收听新的一集。在开始这一集之前，我可以给你们讲个故事吗？这个故事启发了我制作这一集。前几天，当我回到澳大利亚待了一周时，我去了这家澡堂，就像水疗中心一样。这个水疗中心是我们常去的地方。我住在那里的时候，大概每周去一次。它有一个巨大的游泳池，一个浸泡池，一个冷水池，桑拿房，
all the good stuff. And whilst we were there, there was this group of three friends and all of them were on their phones. And I mean they were on their phones in the soak pool. They were on their phones like in the sauna at one stage for like two or three minutes, like sitting around in the quiet spaces, literally like cold plunging all in their phones, not talking, not listening to each other. and I'm going to be honest, I tried very hard not to judge them. I tried very hard to kind of understand maybe why they were doing it, like come up with an explanation. But it really stuck with me.
所有好的设施。当我们去那里时，有一群三个朋友，她们都在玩手机。我是说她们在浸泡池里玩手机。她们在桑拿房里玩手机，大概有两三分钟，坐在安静的空间里，甚至在冷水池里也都在玩手机，不说话，也不听对方说话。老实说，我努力不去评判她们。我努力去理解她们为什么这样做，试图找出一个解释。但这真的让我印象深刻。
It really made me see like perhaps very distinctly and clearly for the first time the intimacy pandemic we are in that has been created by our phones. And I don't mean the fact that our phones are making us lonely. I feel like that's been explored a lot. I don't mean the fact that our phones are addictive or that our screen times are too high. I feel like, sure, that's a part of this. But what really struck me was that even when these people were able to find a time that worked for all of them, they were able to make plans for an in-person hangout, they paid
它真的让我第一次非常清晰地看到了我们所处的亲密关系大流行，这是由我们的手机造成的。我并不是说手机让我们感到孤独。我觉得这一点已经被探讨得很多了。我不是说手机让人上瘾，或者我们的屏幕时间太长。我觉得，当然，这也是其中的一部分。但真正让我震惊的是，即使当这些人能够找到一个适合她们所有人的时间，她们能够计划一次面对面的聚会，她们付了
their $45, they cleared their schedules, they were face-to-face. Like, they'd be all of the odds, overcame all of the difficulties of seeing our friends these days, here they were and they were still on their phones. Their phones were still in the way. They still took priority over real world interaction. And I feel like that was such an obvious example of our phone addiction that, yeah, it basically inspired this episode. Again, like, I wasn't sitting there like shaking my head, judging these people. If anything, I was just kind of profoundly shocked that this was so normalized that you would be in this like serene space with your friends on your phone. And I think we're at a point where it seems like we are progressively
45美元，她们清空了日程，她们面对面了。就像，她们克服了所有困难，克服了如今见朋友的所有障碍，她们来到这里，却依然在玩手机。手机依然挡在中间。它们仍然比现实世界的互动更重要。我觉得这是一个非常明显的手机成瘾的例子，是的，它基本上启发了这一集。再说一次，我并不是坐在那里摇头，评判这些人。如果说有什么的话，我只是对这种现象如此普遍感到深深的震惊，以至于你会和朋友在这样一个宁静的空间里玩手机。我认为我们正处于一个似乎我们正在逐渐
getting more and more sucked in such that this is becoming kind of a normal occurrence. And it's really making me think like, what is the peak of this going to be? And like psychologically, what is the cost to our relationships and to how people continue to make relationships when our phones are always like the third party or the third person in any interaction? So today we are going to explore a different side to our phone and social media use that I don't often see discussed, which is the cost to intimacy. This goes in so many different directions, so many crazy directions that you may not think it goes in. We're not just talking about the cost of too much screen time, but the actual science behind, you know, why you need to remove your phone
被吸入得越来越深，以至于这正在成为一种正常的现象。这真的让我思考，这会达到什么顶峰？从心理学上讲，当手机总是成为任何互动中的第三方或第三个人时，这对我们的关系以及人们如何继续建立关系有什么代价？所以今天我们将探讨我们手机和社交媒体使用的一个不同侧面，我很少看到有人讨论，那就是对亲密关系的代价。这走向了许多不同的方向，许多你可能想不到的疯狂方向。我们不仅仅是在谈论屏幕时间过长的代价，而是背后的实际科学，你知道，为什么你需要把手机从社交场合中移除，
from social situations, why you shouldn't have your phone on the dinner table, why the loss of boredom in our lives created by our phones, means that people know each other less. And of course, you know, five ways that we can reverse this, five ways that we can prevent or stop our phones from taxing our relationships and preventing vulnerability, intimacy and connection in this day and age. So without further ado, let's get into it. Let me start by saying technology, our phones, like, it's obviously made our life so much easier in so many amazing ways. I feel like any episode where somebody just criticizes technology
为什么你不应该把手机放在餐桌上，为什么手机造成的我们生活中无聊感的丧失，意味着人们对彼此的了解更少。当然，你知道，我们可以扭转这种情况的五种方法，五种我们可以防止或阻止手机损害我们的关系，并防止在这个时代建立脆弱性、亲密感和联系的方法。所以事不宜迟，让我们开始吧。首先我要说的是，科技，我们的手机，显然在很多方面让我们的生活变得容易多了。我觉得任何仅仅批评科技的节目
is obviously not very convincing, right? Like phones, technology is responsible, probably for a larger degree of connection that we are experiencing compared to previous generations. you know, how many people have met the love of their life on a dating app? Like, I have, how many of us have been able to sustain long distance friendships, connections, relationships with family because of technology? Literally everybody, you know, I've moved, I don't know what now, like four times as an adult and I can very honestly say I would not still be in touch with a lot of those friends without technology. And that's like fairly obvious to say that. But honestly, like, it has been pretty incredible for human relationships.
显然都不太令人信服，对吧？就像手机、科技，可能要为我们与前几代人相比所经历的更大程度的联系负责。你知道，有多少人在约会软件上遇到了他们的一生挚爱？比如，我就遇到过，我们中有多少人因为科技而能够维持异地友谊、联系、与家人的关系？几乎每个人，你知道，我作为一个成年人已经搬家了，我不知道现在是多少次了，我可以非常诚实地说，如果没有科技，我将无法与许多那些朋友保持联系。说这些话相当明显。但老实说，它对人类关系确实非常不可思议。
However, in this day and age, it is not a hot take to say that most of us, our addiction has gotten to a point where it's no longer just about connection. It's about immediate gratification, which takes away from connection. We were sold this idea with social media and with our phones, that this would improve how we relate to other people. We're now getting to the point, where it's actually taxing relationships. And the addictive nature of our phones is compromising our humanness.
然而，在这个时代，说我们大多数人的成瘾已经到了不再仅仅是关于联系的地步，这并不是什么惊人的言论。它是关于即时满足，这削弱了联系。社交媒体和手机向我们兜售了这个想法，即这将改善我们与他人的关系。我们现在正达到一个地步，它实际上正在损害关系。我们手机的成瘾性正在损害我们的人性。
Like literally, as I'm recording this, I think last week, META and Facebook were forced to pay like a $400 million fine because they designed their technology to be too addictive. And it's been proven by a judge to be hurting social harmony. So I think in response to this, there's been this growing research area. about technoference, technology interference, which basically looks at how technology, something that once brought us closer, is actually becoming a barrier to human connection. Like this is a deep area of study. And it's even creating what one developmental psychologist, her name is Michelle Druin,
就像我录制这一集的时候，我想上周，META和Facebook被迫支付了约4亿美元的罚款，因为他们设计的技术太容易让人上瘾。法官已经证明这正在损害社会和谐。所以我认为作为回应，出现了一个不断增长的研究领域，关于技术干扰（technoference），它基本上研究了技术，这种曾经让我们更亲近的东西，是如何实际上成为人类联系的障碍的。这确实是一个深入的研究领域。它甚至创造了什么一位发展心理学家，她的名字叫米歇尔·德鲁因，
has called an intimacy famine. So essentially, we as humans, we need a certain level of intimacy to sustain ourselves, the same way we need food, water, shelter. air, whatever, and our phones are giving the impression of giving us connection and intimacy, but actually they don't contain any real social nutrition, meaning we're experiencing an intimacy famine without even realizing it. We think that we are getting nutrition from the kind of miniature social interactions we have on our phone.
称之为亲密关系饥荒。所以本质上，我们作为人类，需要一定程度的亲密关系来维持自己，就像我们需要食物、水、住所、空气一样，无论什么，而我们的手机给了我们提供联系和亲密感的印象，但实际上它们不包含任何真正的社会营养，这意味着我们正在经历一场亲密关系饥荒，甚至没有意识到。我们认为我们从手机上的那种微型社交互动中获得了营养。
It's not a real meal. It's not actually feeding us. Why is this the case? well, real intimacy requires presence. We all know that. I'm not saying anything revolutionary. But you cannot connect with somebody if you're not looking at them, listening to them, in their presence, showing engagement. When there is a phone there, when there is a phone on the table, when there is a phone in your hand, it means that presence is interrupted in two ways.
这不是一顿真正的饭。它实际上并没有喂养我们。为什么会这样？嗯，真正的亲密关系需要存在感。我们都知道这一点。我说的不是什么革命性的东西。但如果你不看着他们，不听他们说话，不在他们的存在中，不表现出参与，你就无法与某人建立联系。当那里有一个手机时，当桌子上有一个手机时，当你手里有一个手机时，这意味着存在感在两个方面被打断了。
Firstly, you know, the fact that we are so often on our screens and entertained by our screens just means that our daily need for social interaction is less. Secondly, even when we're interacting with other people, often that presence of our phones actually unconsciously makes people feel snubbed or like our attention could be broken at any moment by this device. And that makes vulnerability hard. It basically stops intimacy. This is what researchers are finding.
首先，你知道，我们经常在屏幕上，被屏幕娱乐，这只是意味着我们对日常社交互动的需求减少了。其次，即使当我们与其他人互动时，手机的存在实际上往往会下意识地让人感到被冷落，或者觉得我们的注意力随时可能被这个设备打断。这使得脆弱性变得困难。它基本上阻止了亲密关系。这就是研究人员发现的。
It stops intimacy from reaching any meaningful level because we can't sustain our attention on a person long enough for them to be vulnerable and for us to create a vulnerable space. Okay, let's start with that primary reason why our phones are ruining presence. And that is that, again, we are just on them all the time. There is this, I guess it's a research body. It's called Cell, Sell, Sell. It's like Sell, Sell.
它阻止了亲密关系达到任何有意义的水平，因为我们无法将注意力维持在一个人身上足够长的时间，让他们展现脆弱，让我们创造一个脆弱的空间。好吧，让我们从手机破坏存在感的那个主要原因开始。那就是，再说一次，我们只是整天都在使用它们。有一个，我想这是一个研究机构。它叫Cell, Sell, Sell。就像Sell, Sell。
It's a phone retail platform. And they did the survey a couple years ago on like 5,000 smartphone owners to understand essentially like once and for all what is the impact of this technology on our dating lives, on our relationships, on our behavior at this point in like humanity's history. And their survey showed that 71% of people spent more time on their phone each day than with their partner. That's nearly three and four people who were in relationships spent more. more time with an inanimate object than someone who they loved and cherished. That same study found that phone use is also reducing the amount of sex that we're having
它是一个手机零售平台。几年前，他们对大约5000名智能手机用户进行了一项调查，旨在从根本上了解这项技术对我们的约会生活、我们的关系、我们在人类历史这一点的行为到底有什么影响。他们的调查显示，71%的人每天花在手机上的时间比花在伴侣身上的时间多。这几乎是四分之三处于恋爱关系中的人，花在无生命物体上的时间比花在他们所爱和珍惜的人身上的时间多。同一项研究发现，手机使用也正在减少我们性生活的频率
and the quality of that sex as well. The statistic literally blew my mind, but they found that one in five people who were spoken to in this study admitted to looking at their phone whilst they were having sex. and the majority of respondents said that their phones were, you know, the last thing they saw before they went to sleep each night, the first thing they saw when they woke up, not their partner. Like, isn't that insane? Like, people, like, checking your phone during sex, that is, like, the level of addiction that we are at. That is the level of, like, I don't even know what's a bigger word than addiction, like dependency. You know what's really interesting about this is,
以及性生活的质量。这个统计数据简直让我大吃一惊，但他们发现，这项研究中接受调查的人中，五分之一的人承认在性生活时看手机。而且大多数受访者表示，手机是他们每天晚上睡觉前看到的最后一样东西，也是他们醒来时看到的第一样东西，而不是他们的伴侣。这不是很疯狂吗？就像，人们在性生活时查看手机，这就是我们所处的成瘾水平。这就是，我甚至不知道有什么比成瘾更大的词，比如依赖。你知道这真正有趣的是，
as much as that is like a shocking statistic, and yet it's surprising, I kind of get where it's coming from, not to play like devil's advocate, but you have to remember that our phones have replaced or have changed the way that we relate to other people. They've also become a way that we soothe loneliness. And when we were out of a relationship or when we were lonely, when we went with friends, whatever it is, the phone is our companion in those moments. One study on, I think it was like 500 Chinese university students, found that the people who had the greatest phone addictions, even when they did have sustained and strong support systems, often had gone through a period where they were very, very lonely.
尽管这是一个令人震惊的统计数据，但它令人惊讶，我有点明白它来自哪里，不是为了扮演魔鬼代言人，但你必须记住，我们的手机已经取代或改变了我们与他人相处的方式。它们也成为我们缓解孤独的一种方式。当我们处于一段关系之外，或者当我们感到孤独时，当我们和朋友在一起时，无论是什么，手机在那些时刻是我们的伴侣。一项关于，我想是大约500名中国大学生的研究发现，那些手机成瘾最严重的人，即使他们确实有持续和强大的支持系统，也经常经历过一段非常、非常孤独的时期。
And that contributed to them feeling a deepest sense of, like, dependency on their phone. basically when we are lonely our phones help us regulate that emotion but in turn they actually make us lonelier even when we do find connection because they give us that small like minute dose of social attention and connection whilst never giving us the full meal basically meaning that they are like breadcrumbing us with real intimacy and at the same time making it harder for us to experience actual in-person intimacy because they're always there so that's the first way to that our phones kind of get in the way. We literally cannot pull away from them, even when we are with other people. The second way they interrupt intimacy or they hurt intimacy is that social snubbing or
这导致他们对手机产生了更深层次的依赖感。基本上，当我们孤独时，我们的手机帮助我们调节那种情绪，但反过来，它们实际上让我们更孤独，即使当我们确实找到了联系，因为它们给了我们那种微小的、分钟级的社交关注和联系，却从未给我们提供完整的饭菜，基本上意味着它们在用真正的亲密关系给我们撒面包屑，同时让我们更难体验到实际的面对面亲密关系，因为它们总是存在。所以这就是手机阻碍我们的第一种方式。我们真的无法离开它们，即使当我们和其他人在一起时。它们打断亲密关系或伤害亲密关系的第二种方式是那种社交冷落或
that concept of phone snubbing that I briefly mentioned before. I think we have all had this experience. I've done this. Let me be real. Where we're talking to our partner, we're talking to our friend, to our boss, to our parent. And suddenly they like pick up their phone to respond to a notification, like right as we are bearing our soul or right as we're like about to eat dinner or engaging with them talking, telling them something important. And suddenly, as soon as that happened, it immediately sends you a signal that they are no longer interested, that they are no longer listening. Somebody picking their phone up at the dinner table is like the technological equivalent of walking away from somebody mid-conversation at a party because somebody more
我之前简要提到的手机冷落（phone snubbing）概念。我想我们都有过这种经历。我也做过。让我说实话。当我们正在和伴侣交谈，我们正在和朋友、老板、父母交谈时。突然他们拿起手机回复通知，就在我们倾诉心声，或者就在我们准备吃晚饭，或者与他们互动交谈，告诉他们重要事情的时候。突然，一旦发生了这种情况，它立即向你发送一个信号，表明他们不再感兴趣，他们不再倾听。某人在餐桌上拿起手机，就像在聚会上在谈话中途走开，因为有人更
interesting came in. That's literally what it is. And it hurts. It really hurts. That's why like I always, well, I don't always do this, but I try hard to, you know, don't eat with your phone at the dinner table. Don't bring your phone to special moments or have it present, especially with the people you love, because that attention grabbing nature is not something that you always have the mental strength to overcome just because you think you can. Studies have been done on this phone snubbing phenomena that we're seeing more and more of and the harm that it's doing to intimacy. And one particular study from 2025 did actually measure they were like, does this hurt people's relationships, like on a level that betrayal might, you know, telling somebody
有趣的人来了，这在技术上是等同的。这确实是它的本质。而且它很伤人。它真的很伤人。这就是为什么我总是，嗯，我不总是这样做，但我努力做到，你知道，不要在餐桌上边吃边玩手机。不要把手机带到特殊的时刻，或者让它在场，特别是和你爱的人在一起时，因为那种吸引注意力的本质不是你总是能有心理力量去克服的，仅仅因为你认为你可以。关于我们看到的越来越多的这种手机冷落现象，以及它对亲密关系造成的伤害，已经进行了研究。2025年的一项特定研究确实测量了，他们想，这是否会伤害人们的关系，就像背叛可能做到的那样，你知道，告诉某人
your secret, telling somebody a story or being vulnerable with them and then having them reach for their phone. Like, what is the emotional reaction that that brings about in somebody? And the results showed that when somebody was in a relationship with somebody who was more prone to using their phone during moments of intimacy, they had greater levels of resentment, greater levels of anger, greater levels of shame even. And over time, this research found that it significantly diminished relationship quality, relationship stability, relationship vulnerability, because there was less and less space or time to meaningfully share. to meaningfully connect. And the thing is, is like, vulnerability and intimacy are freaking hard. Like, it is hard to sit in front of somebody and say, this is what I'm struggling with. This is what is really impacting me. This is what I feel is missing in our relationship, whatever it is. And for somebody should then essentially send you the signal that, like,
你的秘密，告诉某人一个故事，或者对他们展现脆弱，然后让他们去拿手机。这在某人身上带来了什么样的情感反应？结果显示，当某人与一个在亲密时刻更容易使用手机的人处于恋爱关系中时，他们有更高水平的怨恨、更高水平的愤怒，甚至更高水平的羞耻感。随着时间的推移，这项研究发现，它显著降低了关系质量、关系稳定性、关系脆弱性，因为有意义地分享、有意义地联系的空间或时间越来越少。而且问题是，脆弱性和亲密关系是非常困难的。就像，坐在某人面前说，这是我正在挣扎的事情，这是真正影响我的事情，这是我觉得我们关系中缺失的东西，无论是什么，这很难。而某人随后基本上向你发送信号，表明，
this inanimate object, my phone is more important than this conversation. Like, that is going to shut down future attempts at intimacy and it's going to mean that the bond suffers as well. Another study from 2019 again, it's just basically reiterating the same finding, which is that technoference causes feelings of rejection. It causes feelings of dismissal. And it is like this silent killer of relationship these days. This study went more in depth and it actually asked people to keep like a diary over 14 days of like how often their phone was interrupting their relationship. And 72% of these couples who were involved in the study said, now that I notice it, now that I'm thinking about it, like this phone, this technology is creating
这个无生命的物体，我的手机比这次谈话更重要。这将会关闭未来尝试亲密关系的大门，这也意味着纽带也会受到损害。2019年的另一项研究，同样，它基本上重申了同样的发现，即技术干扰会导致被拒绝的感觉。它会导致被忽视的感觉。而且它就像这些天关系的沉默杀手。这项研究进行了更深入的调查，它实际上要求人们在14天内写日记，记录他们的手机打断他们关系的频率。参与这项研究的这些夫妇中，72%的人说，现在我注意到了，现在我在思考它，就像这个手机，这项技术正在创造
an interference in our relationship. They also reported higher phone usage during the day correlating to more conflict, more irritability, more anger. So there was like multiple, multiple interruptions that were happening. So I just think that this is like a very powerful reminder to not see your phone as this like passive harmless object, but to understand the power and the ability it has to damage even like your closest relationships without you even realizing. The other thing that our phones and social media have done that I think is killing relationships and more so friendships is that they have strange.
对我们关系的干扰。他们还报告说，白天手机使用率越高，与更多的冲突、更多的易怒、更多的愤怒相关联。所以发生了多次、多次的打断。所以我只是认为这是一个非常有力的提醒，不要把你的手机看作是一个被动的、无害的物体，而是要理解它在甚至你最亲密的关系中造成损害的能力和力量，而你甚至没有意识到。手机和社交媒体所做的另一件事，我认为正在扼杀关系，尤其是友谊，是它们已经变得奇怪。
also commodified friendship so that it's become this like tit for tat online way of engaging with one another. I think especially with social media, basically we now show loyalty to our friends not by showing up for them in person, not by helping them physically, not by being around them more sharing experiences, but also and more so showing up in likes, showing up in comments, showing up in social media engagement, being present in their online lives more than their in-person lives. It's like this extra layer that we are now all having to prove ourselves on in our friendships that like you can give somebody so much when it comes to your in-person friendship, but there's this level of like online loyalty that if we don't live up to,
也商品化了友谊，以至于它变成了这种在线的、礼尚往来的互动方式。我认为特别是社交媒体，基本上我们现在向朋友展示忠诚，不是通过亲自出现支持他们，不是通过在身体上帮助他们，不是通过更多地与他们分享经历，而是更多地通过点赞、评论、社交媒体互动来展示，在他们的在线生活中比在他们的现实生活中更活跃。这就像是我们现在在友谊中都必须证明自己的一层额外的东西，就像你可以在面对面的友谊中给予某人很多，但有一种在线忠诚度的水平，如果我们不达到，
creates a lot of resentment. And I think that's something that not, that like doesn't get spoken about enough. The way that social media and our phones have downgraded physical intimacy and downgraded like a real social connection and upgraded a kind of fictional online connection of liking, engaging, commenting. Like, I'm sure we've all had this feeling of posting, like, I don't know, a photo that you think is amazing or a story and expect. like your friends to comment on it, expecting your friends to respond, whatever it is, and them not, and feeling hurt. Like, the new rules and the new playbook for friendship online and the fact that like, you know, it's understood but not always communicated means that there are more
会产生很多怨恨。我认为这是没有被足够讨论的事情。社交媒体和我们的手机降低了身体亲密感，降低了真正的社会联系，并升级了一种虚构的在线联系，即点赞、互动、评论。就像，我相信我们都有过这种感觉，发布，我不知道，一张你认为很棒的照片或故事，并期待你的朋友评论它，期待你的朋友回应，无论是什么，而他们没有，并感到受伤。就像，在线友谊的新规则和新剧本，以及事实上，你知道，它是被理解但并不总是被沟通的，意味着有更多
and more of these like small slights and these small sense of betrayals that come with friendship being converted into like online interactions. Can I talk about one final way I think that our phones are killing intimacy that also doesn't always make this conversation? Hot take. Our phones are killing intimacy because none of us know how to be bored anymore. And the thing is, is that when you're bored, when you're sitting around with your friends,
和更多的这些小小的怠慢和这些小小的背叛感，伴随着友谊被转化为在线互动。我可以谈谈我认为手机正在扼杀亲密关系的最后一个方式吗？这也不总是出现在这个对话中。惊人言论。手机正在扼杀亲密关系，因为我们都不再知道如何感到无聊了。问题是，当你感到无聊时，当你和朋友坐在一起时，
maybe like twiddling your thumbs, that is when you truly get to know people. because you naturally fill those silences with stories, with personal details, with vulnerability that creates closeness. Because you're kind of like, there's this empty space and people step into it. Nowadays, we don't get that anymore because when you're bored at the function, when you're bored of the party, when you're bored at dinner, like you pick up your phone. And immediately that opportunity for vulnerability and to connect is like shut off in that moment.
也许像转动你的拇指，那才是你真正了解人们的时候。因为你自然地用故事、个人细节、脆弱性填补了那些沉默，从而创造了亲密感。因为你有点像，有一个空的空间，人们走进了它。如今，我们不再得到那个了，因为当你在活动中感到无聊时，当你在聚会上感到无聊时，当你在晚餐时感到无聊时，你拿起你的手机。那一刻，脆弱和联系的机会在瞬间就被关闭了。
And it's so ironic that then we all kind of walk around wondering why our friendships aren't as deep these days. But like to get close to somebody, there is going to be that level of discomfort that you have to sit in to get to know them more. And we are stopping that discomfort with technology. I think that's really what it is. Like we can't just sit alone with our thoughts when we are alone. We can't sit alone with our thoughts when we're with other people. The moment we feel a hard emotion or we feel awkward, Instead of like forging through, which is what you have to do for friendship,
讽刺的是，然后我们都走来走去，想知道为什么这些天我们的友谊不再那么深了。但要接近某人，你必须坐在那里忍受那种不适感，才能更多地了解他们。而我们正在用科技阻止那种不适感。我认为这才是真正的本质。就像我们独自一人时，我们不能独自坐在那里思考。当我们和别人在一起时，我们不能独自坐在那里思考。当我们感到一种强烈的情绪或感到尴尬时，而不是像坚持下去，这是你为了友谊必须做的，
we kind of retreat into something comfortable that will soothe us with like this nice, constant trickle of easy dopamine, but it's actually avoidance and it's actually hurting our relationships and our ability to really get to know people. That's just my theory. I feel like people have other theories about it, but the boredom one is like is huge. Okay, let's actually explore the psychology behind why this has come to be. and why it is that even if you understand all of this,
我们退缩到某种舒适的东西中，它会用这种持续的、简单的多巴胺涓流来安抚我们，但这实际上是逃避，它实际上正在伤害我们的关系以及我们真正了解人们的能力。这只是我的理论。我觉得人们对此有其他理论，但无聊那个理论是巨大的。好吧，让我们真正探讨一下为什么会变成这样的心理学。以及为什么即使你理解了所有这些，
you still cannot pull yourself away from this technology because it's not you. There are actually some deep, I don't know, conspiratorial conspiracies, controversies behind these addictive patterns and behind why all of us I think now have a boundary and a dependency issue with our phones. So stay with us. 2%.
你仍然无法让自己远离这项技术，因为那不是你。实际上有一些深刻的，我不知道，阴谋论，这些成瘾模式背后的争议，以及为什么我认为我们现在所有人对手机都有界限和依赖问题。所以请留下来。2%。
That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了在这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家以及更多人交谈，以看透主导健康产业的不切实际和过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上是炎症性的。我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J.
让自己经历一些磨难，你就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。那是T-W-O-Persent，在I-Hart广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crime. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，大谈80年代的快克。明确一点，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为犯罪。快克。我愿意谈论快克，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看到有一条主线。
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts.
我们现在桌面上还有艾滋病。谢谢你完成那句话。我不认为有比这更重要的年份了，对黑人来说。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说最重要的年份之一。在IHeart广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade
欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们的主持人，也是你们最喜欢的治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了超过十年的
of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fantine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit
我在心理健康领域的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我在谈论。特里普·范廷，瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求
of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候已经做得足够了。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得做一个好人很重要，当你在这个地球上时？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两种不同程度的信任。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now.
我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的IHeart广播应用程序，搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开始了一场长达数年的法庭斗争，以证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用于什么。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the Westby and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
他们揭开了一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，韦斯特比和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice of. served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在Iheart广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要招惹乡村女孩。
You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
你玩愚蠢的游戏，你就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在这个新一季的《The Girlfriends》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得我被卡车撞了。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends.
我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎并不关心。所以她们决定采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。收听《The Girlfriends》。
Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Like I said before, our phones offer this like bite-sized ecosystem of what socializing and connection used to be in just like a highly addictive commodified format. We already know that. We already know that that's really what gets us hooked, especially to social media. Beyond that, though, the reason they keep getting in the way of intimacy is that they have also become one of the primary ways that we regulate our emotions.
相信我，宝贝。在Iheart广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。就像我之前说的，我们的手机提供了一个微型的生态系统，关于社交和联系曾经是什么样子，只是以一种高度成瘾的、商品化的格式。我们已经知道了。我们已经知道这才是真正让我们上瘾的东西，特别是社交媒体。然而，除此之外，它们继续阻碍亲密关系的原因是，它们也已经成为我们调节情绪的主要方式之一。
much like any addictive substance or object, really. That's really the root of all addiction. It stops us from feeling the bad feelings. And like all addiction, the cycle has to begin with intoxication. The substance has to initially be too good to say no to. Our phones do this. Our phones are too good to say no to. They feel good because that was an intentional design choice.
就像任何成瘾物质或物体一样，真的。这确实是所有成瘾的根源。它阻止我们感受糟糕的情绪。像所有成瘾一样，循环必须从陶醉开始。物质最初必须太好而无法拒绝。我们的手机做到了这一点。我们的手机太好而无法拒绝。它们感觉很好，因为那是一个故意的设计选择。
Like, they are designed to capture as much attention as possible. when they were designing early models of the iPhone, the team behind them, like hired neuroscientists, hired psychologists, hired scientists onto their design teams, like onto their prototype teams, and essentially their mission was how can we break the brain's feedback loop and reward loop so that people are obsessed with this, so that this becomes the new way of life? How do we get people addicted? they added so many features into the design of these devices that it actually created a name. It's called persuasive design.
就像，它们被设计为尽可能多地捕捉注意力。当他们设计iPhone的早期型号时，背后的团队，比如聘请了神经科学家，聘请了心理学家，聘请了科学家进入他们的设计团队，比如进入他们的原型团队，本质上他们的使命是如何打破大脑的反馈循环和奖励循环，以便人们对它着迷，以便这成为新的生活方式？我们如何让人上瘾？他们在这些设备的设计中添加了太多的功能，以至于它实际上创造了一个名字。它被称为说服性设计。
Basically making it harder for you to say no to the object than to say yes, basically meaning that the path of least resistance is the one that you don't always want to choose, but you just constantly go down. Another way to describe this, another psychological idea that explains this is called Nudge Theory. And nudge theory essentially says, again, your phones have been designed to give you the impression of choice. But in actuality, every choice you make, like when to pick up your phone, how long to scroll for, when to turn it off, you are actually being subtly nudged towards by design features that were intended to get you into that space. Like, I feel like that's all words. I'll give you some examples.
基本上让你更难拒绝这个物体，而不是说同意，本质上意味着阻力最小的路径是你并不总是想选择的，但你却不断地走下去。描述这一点的另一种方式，解释这一点的另一种心理学思想被称为助推理论（Nudge Theory）。助推理论本质上说，再说一次，你的手机被设计为给你选择的印象。但实际上，你做的每一个选择，比如什么时候拿起手机，滚动多久，什么时候关掉它，你实际上是被设计功能微妙地推动的，这些功能旨在让你进入那个空间。就像，我觉得那都是废话。我会给你一些例子。
The best example is, like, the use of blue light rather than more warm light. Blue light is more attention grabbing than natural light, meaning it's harder to pull your eyes away from the screen. I also feel like even the design of the screen gets us trapped. Like, that small screen, it occupies your whole field of vision. It basically gives you tunnel vision compared to a TV, compared to an iPad, compared to even a laptop. Even like the size of these items,
最好的例子是，比如使用蓝光而不是更温暖的光。蓝光比自然光更吸引注意力，这意味着更难把你的眼睛从屏幕上移开。我也觉得屏幕的设计甚至让我们被困住了。就像，那个小屏幕，它占据了你的整个视野。与电视、iPad、甚至笔记本电脑相比，它基本上给了你隧道视野。甚至像这些物品的大小，
it's so hard for your vision to like pull away from it. We get sucked in intentionally. And that's before we even add on other features of apps that were designed with the phone in mind, like the infinite scroll of social media, all these other addictive properties that we could get into. Essentially like it is you against a team of very smart people who essentially were paid to get you hooked.
你的视线很难从中移开。我们被故意吸进去了。这甚至在我们添加其他考虑到手机的应用程序功能之前，比如社交媒体的无限滚动，所有其他我们可以深入研究的成瘾属性。本质上，这是你对抗一群非常聪明的人，他们本质上是被付钱让你上瘾的。
There's the same developmental psychologist I mentioned before, Michelle Drewon. She's done so much research on this and she speaks about, I think it was in her book, she speaks about how she realized she had a problem with her phone when she began to understood that her phone behaved just like someone close to her in her life. It made noises, it commanded her attention, it asked her to resolve issues, alerted her to problems. It like basically communicated with her. And she talks about like how we groom our phone to like remove smudges, how we always have it close to us. We become nervous if we can't find it or if the battery dies. Again, dying. Like our phone is almost this human thing. We've essentially
我之前提到过一位发展心理学家，米歇尔·德鲁翁（Michelle Drewon）。她对此做了大量研究，我想是在她的书中，她提到当她开始意识到手机的行为就像她生命中亲近的人一样时，她意识到自己对手机产生了依赖。它会发出声音，吸引她的注意力，要求她解决问题，提醒她各种状况。它基本上是在与她交流。她谈到我们如何“打理”手机，比如擦掉污迹，如何总是把它带在身边。如果我们找不到它，或者电池没电了，我们就会变得焦虑。再说一次，没电了。就像我们的手机几乎成了某种人类一样。我们本质上已经
come to, I don't know if it's like anthropomorphize, but like assign our phones with human qualities, assigned this non-human object with the characteristics that a friend would have or a partner would have. And that alters our emotional and cognitive response to that object, meaning we feel a greater sense of dependency, meaning we feel like us and our phones are in a relationship. They fulfilled the psychological needs and the psychological deficits that have come with friendship being harder, relationships being harder, that they created. Like, it has replaced the need for a real world companion, essentially. Not always, but like, in a small way.
开始，我不知道这是否叫拟人化，但我们赋予了手机人类的特质，将这种非人类的物体赋予了朋友或伴侣才有的特征。这改变了我们对该物体的感官和认知反应，意味着我们感到更强烈的依赖感，意味着我们觉得我们和手机之间存在一种关系。它们满足了心理需求，填补了因友谊变得困难、人际关系变得复杂而产生的心理缺失。它们创造了这种需求。就像，它本质上取代了对现实世界伴侣的需求。不总是这样，但在某种程度上确实如此。
When we rely upon an inanimate object to fulfill our intimate emotional needs, of course that is going to have bleed on effects to how we eventually, and as a society begin to relate to one another. And that's why I think, you know, when the question comes up of like, why does this matter? Well, it matters because human relationships matter. And they are much more important than a relationship with an inanimate object. But if you are not conscious and if you are not cognizant of how much time you are spending with this device and spending with this technology, pretty soon it can become your primary relationship.
当我们依赖一个无生命的物体来满足我们亲密的心理需求时，这当然会波及到我们最终以及作为一个社会如何开始与他人建立联系。这就是为什么我认为，当出现“这有什么关系？”这样的问题时，答案是：这很重要，因为人际关系很重要。它们比与无生命物体的关系重要得多。但如果你没有意识到，如果你没有意识到你在这个设备和这项技术上花费了多少时间，很快它就会成为你的主要关系。
I had this realization a few years ago when I started truly calculating how many days of my life I literally miss per year from being on my phone. Are you ready for this number? If you have a screen time of six hours a day, you will spend 90 days each year on your phone. That is 990 full days on a screen. Consuming things that you will likely not remember in 24 hours time. Let that sink in. 90 days. If I'm being honest, I have that problem. I know a lot of people have that problem. I'm not going to sit here and claim to be like this person who has the perfect relationship with
几年前，当我真正开始计算我每年因为玩手机而浪费了多少天生命时，我有了这个认识。准备好听这个数字了吗？如果你的屏幕使用时间是每天六小时，你每年将在手机上花费90天。那是990个整天都在屏幕上。消耗着你可能在24小时内就会忘记的东西。让这个事实沉淀一下。90天。老实说，我有这个问题。我知道很多人都有这个问题。我不会坐在这里声称自己是一个与
technology and with her phone. However, I do feel like we need some new strategies because that is a lot of time that we cannot get back. And that is a lot of time that if we are being honest, would be better spent with the people we love, actually physically experiencing the world, or like at least working or caring about something that is more permanent and more meaningful. The way that we are going to do this is essentially adding friction back in where these technology companies took friction out. Essentially make it harder to use technology. Have boundaries the way that you would for like a toxic relationship, right? I will also say if you want to experiment with going phone free or at least smartphone free, it's actually not as doom and gloom as you may think.
技术和手机有着完美关系的人。然而，我觉得我们需要一些新的策略，因为那是我们无法挽回的大量时间。如果说实话，这些时间如果花在我们爱的人身上，去真实地体验世界，或者至少去工作或关心一些更持久、更有意义的事情，会更好。我们实现这一目标的方法本质上是重新引入摩擦力，而这些科技公司正是去除了摩擦力。本质上就是让使用技术变得更难。像对待一段有毒的关系一样设定界限，对吧？我还想说，如果你想尝试不使用手机，或者至少不使用智能手机，其实并没有你想象的那么悲观。
There is this whole social movement of people right now going smartphone free, going technology free, going social media free. And as much as I'm not going to again recommend it, like early studies do show they are a lot happier. even if they lose some convenience. Like they are doing better than most of us. A study from 2018 had 300 people just share a single meal at a restaurant with their family and friends and they either had their phone on the table or had their phone put away.
现在有一个完整的社会运动，人们正在尝试不使用智能手机，不使用技术，不使用社交媒体。虽然我不会再次推荐它，但早期研究确实表明他们快乐得多，即使他们失去了一些便利。他们比我们大多数人做得更好。2018年的一项研究让300人与家人和朋友在餐厅共进一餐，他们要么把手机放在桌子上，要么把手机收起来。
And those people just in that moment had an increased level of happiness and social harmony and fulfillment compared to the people who, had their phones present. So even in those small moments, like choosing to resist does make you feel better. Another study found, things from like 2024, three quarters of people who left their phones at home just for a day also felt happier in the long run. That impact, I think, lasted like a week. And the final study I want to talk about here is this 2025 study that found that going without social media and the internet for two weeks, psychologically, and emotionally reset people's entire moods going forward.
那些在那个时刻的人，与手机在场的人相比，幸福感、社会和谐感和满足感都有所提高。所以即使在那些小瞬间，选择抵制确实会让你感觉更好。另一项2024年的研究发现，四分之三的人仅仅因为一天把手机留在家里，从长远来看也感到更快乐。我认为这种影响持续了大约一周。我想在这里谈的最后一项研究是2025年的这项研究，它发现两周不使用社交媒体和互联网，在心理和情感上重置了人们之后的心情。
91% of the people in this experiment felt better in the weeks and months afterwards. That's the option here. Setting boundaries, creating more friction, having those phone-free periods, having those phone-free moments, months. You don't have to start with two weeks. I think just start with designing your home to be less technology-friendly. Having like no phone zones in your house or like a designated phone zone, I think is like an incredibly important strategy here.
这项实验中91%的人在随后的几周和几个月里感觉更好。这就是这里的选择。设定界限，创造更多摩擦力，拥有那些无手机时期，拥有那些无手机的时刻、月份。你不必从两周开始。我认为只需从设计你的家，使其不那么适合技术使用开始。在家里设置无手机区域，或者指定一个手机区域，我认为这是一个非常重要的策略。
I saw this woman talk about the always be charging trick in like this New York Times article. So essentially what she's doing to stop her phone from interrupting her relationship and stop her phone from interrupting her life is that she says, I can use my phone as much as I want. But if I'm going to use it, it must always be charging. and she only has a charger in one spot in her house. She even speaks about needing, I think she needed like a recipe for something. And she, like, obviously she can't bring her phone to the kitchen. So she like hand wrote the recipe from her phone and went kind of analog with it.
我在《纽约时报》的一篇文章中看到一位女士谈论“始终充电”的技巧。所以本质上，为了阻止手机干扰她的人际关系和生活，她所做的是：她说，我可以随心所欲地使用手机。但如果我要使用它，它必须始终在充电。而且她家里只有一个地方有充电器。她甚至提到需要，我想她是需要某个食谱。显然她不能把手机带到厨房，所以她手写了手机上的食谱，并以一种模拟的方式使用它。
It's not completely taking away the need for technology or the use of it. It's just creating guardrails. Phone free evenings as well. I feel like just saying two days a week, two afternoons a week, I'm just not going to to have my phone on me. I'm going to go out. I'm going to risk it. I'm going to see my friends without my phone. Or I'm going to get to the restaurant and put my phone away is also incredibly valuable. And again, those studies show add intimacy back into our relationships. You know, because it's not always the phone. It's like, it's social media specifically. Deleting social media
这并不是完全消除对技术的需求或使用。它只是在建立护栏。无手机的夜晚也是如此。我觉得只要说每周两天，每周两个下午，我不带手机。我要出去。我要冒险。我要在不带手机的情况下见朋友。或者我要到餐厅把手机收起来，这也非常有价值。再说一次，那些研究表明这会增加我们人际关系的亲密度。你知道，因为并不总是手机的问题。而是社交媒体的问题。删除社交媒体
when you walk through the door or only having it on your laptop. I was doing this for a while. I was like, I can only go on social media when I'm outside my house. So like when I walk, like when I walk back in the door, I don't know, 5pm, 6 p.m. Like that app is getting deleted. And then when I leave the next morning, like that's when I can re-download it. Just creating, again, guard rails that say that essentially communicate to yourself. Like this is not going to be the thing that's allowed to dominate my life. Like this is not going to be this omnipresent thing.
当你走进家门时，或者只在笔记本电脑上使用它。我有一段时间就是这样做的。我说，我只能在屋外使用社交媒体。所以当我走回门内，比如下午5点、6点，那个应用程序就会被删除。然后第二天早上我离开时，那才是我可以重新下载它的时候。再次建立护栏，本质上是在与自己沟通。这不会成为主宰我生活的东西。这不会成为这种无处不在的东西。
I am actually in control of this technology and what I want to do with it and what it gets to do with me. And even just creating that tiny bit of friction of like deleting the app, maybe what it takes to just, I don't know, let it release this like kind of grip from your mind. Also like social media free weekends, I feel like I'm just throwing heaps of things at you guys. And having like obviously abstinence is one thing, not spending a lot. as much time on your phone is one thing, not spending as much time on social media is one thing, but it's not going to be effective unless you also have alternative habits for when you're bored, for when you're sad, for when you're lonely. Again, the real reason and the main reason, I would say that technology and our phones and our relationship to our phones have gotten to the
我实际上是在控制这项技术，以及我想用它做什么，它能对我做什么。即使只是创造那一点点删除应用程序的摩擦力，也许就是让你从这种心理束缚中解脱出来所需要的。还有，比如无社交媒体的周末，我觉得我只是在向你们抛出很多东西。显然禁欲是一回事，不花那么多时间在手机上是一回事，不花那么多时间在社交媒体上是一回事，但除非你也有替代习惯，否则它是不会有效的，比如当你无聊时，当你难过时，当你孤独时。再说一次，我认为技术、我们的手机以及我们与手机的关系之所以达到
addictive point that they have is because they have become the sole way that we know how to deal with hard feelings. And so having a strategy, having some, something else that you can do when those hard feelings comes up, starts to interrupt that dependency cycle that begins with boredom, that begins with sadness or loneliness, where the only kind of antidote we have now is to scroll as a distraction, is to put on a TV show in the background as a distraction. Give yourself an alternative. Give yourself, I don't know, a journal practice, give yourself, have a puzzle that you're doing, have a friend that you call instead, have anything in your home, in your life that you can do first before you immediately like
成瘾程度的真正原因和主要原因，是因为它们已经成为我们处理困难情绪的唯一方式。因此，制定一个策略，拥有一些当你出现那些困难情绪时可以做的其他事情，就开始打断那个依赖循环。这个循环始于无聊，始于悲伤或孤独，而我们现在唯一的解药就是通过滚动屏幕来分散注意力，就是通过在后台播放电视节目来分散注意力。给自己一个替代方案。给自己，我不知道，一个写日记的习惯，给自己，玩一个拼图，或者给朋友打个电话，在你的家里，在你的生活中，在你立即
pick up your phone to avoid and suppress whatever bad thing it is that you are feeling. I think at the end of the day, this is somewhat of a value thing, right? You cannot change your relationship with this technology unless you have a deep moment with yourself and seriously consider what do I value more? Quick dopamine or deep connection? Because that's really what we're going up against. Do we want short-term gratification or long-term gratification? The phone offers short-term gratification, relationships offer long-term gratification. And keeping that number in mind, actually doing the math with your screen time, how many days are you losing. How many years of your life are you to this object, to this inanimate object, I think
拿起手机去逃避和压抑你所感受到的任何糟糕情绪之前，做任何你可以做的事情。我认为归根结底，这在某种程度上是一个价值观问题，对吧？除非你与自己进行深刻的对话，认真考虑我更看重什么？是快速的多巴胺还是深层的联系？因为这才是我们真正面对的问题。我们想要短期满足还是长期满足？手机提供短期满足，人际关系提供长期满足。记住那个数字，真正计算你的屏幕时间，你正在失去多少天。你在这个物体，这个无生命物体上浪费了多少年，我认为
is the motivation we need to have healthier habits. So I think I'm going to wrap the episode up there. I feel like this was a very ranty episode. We touched on some psychology, but really I think the through line is just be more conscious about how technology is interrupting intimacy, genuinely acknowledge if this has and this continues to create problems in your relationships and whether you want it to continue to create that problem in your relationship and apply some of those strategies. Add the friction back in so that being present with your friends, being present with your partner, with your family is the easier thing to do. And being online, being on social media, being your phone, is that.
是我们养成更健康习惯所需的动力。所以我认为我要在这里结束这一集。我觉得这是一集非常爱唠叨的节目。我们触及了一些心理学，但我认为主线只是要更清醒地意识到技术是如何干扰亲密关系的，真正承认这是否已经并将继续在你的关系中制造问题，以及你是否希望它继续在你的关系中制造问题，并应用其中一些策略。重新加入摩擦力，这样与朋友在一起、与伴侣在一起、与家人在一起就变得更容易。而上网、使用社交媒体、使用手机，是那个
the harder path, is the path with more resistance. All right, let's wrap it up. I want to thank our researcher Lucy Davidson for her help with this episode. If you have made it this far, leave a little phone emoji down below so that I know that you listened all the way to the end. And if you have any more strategies around how you're going to reshape, change your relationship with technology, I'd also love to hear it below. Make sure that you're following us on Instagram.
更难的路径，是阻力更大的路径。好了，让我们结束吧。我要感谢我们的研究员露西·戴维森（Lucy Davidson）对本集提供的帮助。如果你已经看到了这里，请在下方留下一个手机表情符号，这样我就知道你听到了最后。如果你有更多关于如何重塑、改变你与技术关系的策略，我也很想在下方听到。确保你在Instagram上关注我们。
If you are listening on Spotify or Apple as well, you may not know, but the podcast is now on Netflix. So if you want a more visual experience, if you want to watch video episodes, there will be a link in the description. In fact, there are many links in the description that I'm just going to turn your attention to if you want to follow us by the book, read the substacks, watch the video episodes, all the self-promotion goes on down there. I don't know if I have anything else to say, just that I hope you enjoyed this episode and that I don't know, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
如果你也在Spotify或Apple上收听，你可能不知道，但这个播客现在也在Netflix上。所以如果你想要更直观的体验，如果你想观看视频剧集，描述中会有一个链接。事实上，描述中有很多链接，如果你想通过书关注我们，阅读Substack，观看视频剧集，所有的自我推广都在下面。我不知道我还有什么要说的，只是希望你喜欢这一集，并且，我不知道，注意安全，善良，对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再谈。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。我在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会从另一端走出来，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。在《Look Back at it》播客中。对于1979年，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。
84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year.
84年对我来说很重要。我是萨姆·J（Sam J）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会选择一年，剖析发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何幸存下来的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
我不认为对黑人来说有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人，基尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，在任何地方都不安全，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same.
仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA电台应用程序、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一个骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有两个经历过同样事情的男人。
same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
同样的事情。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着季节的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们采取了行动。我发誓。成为他的最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。听听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。
On the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在IHeart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是人类制作的。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。